s'il est un vin de circonstance pour
fêter la saint valentin c'est bien le
saint-amour ce cru du beaujolais doit
son appellation à un couple de vignerons
thérèse et louis dailly marie-hélène
bono et pascal puyoô nous raconte cette
belle histoire d'amour il il ya tout
juste 50 ans le saint-amour était
officiellement reconnu crus du
beaujolais
grâce à la dévotion d'un homme louis
dailly toute sa vie il l'a consacré à la
vigne et à lutter pour que son vin soit
reconnue aujourd'hui sa femme à 82 ans
continue son oeuvre
quand on est amoureux de sa ville et
puis quand un homme a fait don de sa vie
pour que son amour continuer n'est ce
pas un modèle de produire je pense que
de son ciel ils envoient aussi entre
temps ses bénédictions
alors y est vous nous formons toujours
ce même couple
thérèse et louis un couple hors du
commun
en 1936 il se marie dix ans plus tard le
saint-amour aînés et baptisé vins
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée
aujourd'hui perez dailly produit encore
dix mille bouteilles par an qu'est ce
que je ferais si je n'avais plus ni vis
ni si je n'avais plus mon vin là qu'est
ce que vous voulez mon vin à l'âme en
vain ses essais ses jeux puisque nous
sommes à la saint-valentin là c'est mon
grand amour c'est le seul comprennent la
coutume veut que ce soit une femme qui
goûte la première le saint-amour
cuvée spéciale pour la saint-valentin
forcément n'ai rien n'empêche d'en boire
tout au long de l'année pour le tas
d'amour il n'y a pas de saison